what is in your mind uh society's vision
of like the perfect man right like what
does that look like today in today's
society it's a good question because i
think today's society we have a lot of
like femme centric systems whether it's
like the education system um the
judiciary system they're all femme
centered so
what does that mean femme centered it
means that it's women who are raising
men or like teaching boys so you have
more
more female teachers in schools and they
say to boys it's okay to cry it's okay
you know they're not teaching them
mental resilience and and how to become
a strong man how to become a strong
adult um you know the judiciary system
if for if a man and a woman are together
they're married and um you know say she
cheats or whatever it is they get
divorced she gets half his money and the
kids you know it's very sem femme
centric um and so it's the woman that's
in charge we keep talking about like um
you know the patriarchy the patriarchy
is dead we live in a matriarchy whereby
men i think get the brunt of everything
i don't think even marriage is a good
deal for men either why not
for what i just said because of the
judiciary system um because like
basically in the in the downside case
the men get screwed exactly exactly
whereas a woman is always going to be
safe and also we have to consider how
men and women are viewed in society
again we talk about this so-called
patriarchy but it's women who are valued
more than men we want equality but like
what does equality even mean i think
women are intrinsically valued on a
higher level to men because it's the
women and the children that are always
protected first it's the men that are
sent off to war it's the men that are
more disposable
as a man like i said you have to become
and a woman can just be so it's like
society doesn't care about you until you
become something um and nobody wants to
talk about that and i think we should
talk about it the reason we should talk
about it is because i think the dynamics
between men and women would just be
better like i think that um with the
correct with healthy masculinity um
femininity can can thrive in that kind
of space
and if we stop men from being masculine
and we stop women from being feminine
the genders just
melt into each other and it becomes a
mess and there's a lot of toxicity and
so nobody wants to talk about the fact
that men are disposable in this world
well there's obviously the old like
phrase you know hard times make strong
men and and kind of go through the whole
thing and eventually what you get is
good times and then good times make weak
man and weak men make hard times um and
so when we think about that is that just
like a natural cycle that we've seen
throughout civilizations or is this
something new where american society is
uh
taking the idea of what it is to be a
man and changing it or have we seen in
the past after the roman empire fell
like was there some point in time where
uh no men were supposed to cry and do
all these different things because it
was no longer about uh kind of the
dominance of kind of ancient rome or is
this something that you think is brand
new i think there's two
pivotal parts in modern day i mean i'm
only in my 20s so i can't think too far
back but let's just take the 60s right
the 60s is an amazing example because
that was basically the liberation of
women um that's basically when women
didn't need men right it's feminism
because feminism empowers women um what
is feminism
which wave
how do you tell me feminism ultimately
if you speak to a feminist she's going
to say oh it's about the equality of men
and women i don't think it is anymore
it's about the woman's right to choose
her own destiny and i think that's i
think that's important i think that's
great um you know i clearly have my own
career or whatever but that's because i
believe in individual empowerment i
think everybody should be um empowered
to save themselves as a woman you
shouldn't rely on
a husband you shouldn't rely on the
government you shouldn't rely on daddy
whatever you need to be empowered
because you don't know what's coming
tomorrow right what if your husband dies
what if you're you know whatever um and
so that's essential
but we're now at a point whereby
feminism i think has gone too far
so um you know if you hold the door for
a man sorry if a man holds the door for
you what are you doing i can hold my own
door um and like these these things are
so integrated into society i'm from
london and when i was 21 i used to work
as a journalist and i carried all this
heavy equipment by myself on the london
underground up and down the stairs not
one man ever offered to help me because
he was i could see it they looked at me
but oh should i should i not should i
i'm like yes help me i'm a little woman
it's okay i'm not offended right um but
they never did because they were um
afraid that they would offend me um and
i think feminism has gone too far it's
now rejecting um the feminine they're
trying to say well you know what is it
why is why is soft and nurturing
feminine because it is and that's okay
um so i feel like they are rejecting
that um and we sort of spoke about
earlier but there's like this pendulum
that's going on and i think we've gone
way too far one way um and now the likes
of like andrew tay and you know this
kind of content are pushing people the
other way and making people more
comfortable about talking about these
things i also think the reason why i'm
so vocal about this some people say to
me are you doing it for clicks you're
doing it because it's a really good
niche it's not true like i want to get
married like i'm single i want to get
married and i want to find um a
masculine man you know
and
that's and and so that's hard because
there aren't so many masculine men left
because they don't know how to be
because of the fem-centric systems that
we spoke about um you know it's okay to
cry it's okay to that like the fact of
the matter is your wife doesn't want to
see you cry she doesn't want to see you
struggle she all she wants is safety and
that's it so if you're looking weak
that's going to worry her and so the
respect for you declines and again
people don't like this reality but i
think these conversations are really
important hey you did you like this
video great make sure you subscribe like
the video and see you next time